hey a special snowflake Donald Trump
lead to a safe space is it fleet or fled
but oh it's Flint I don't know fleed I'm
not sure anyway
special snowflake Trump went to a safe
space and canceled a speech at the
Israeli Knesset to avoid being heckled
you'll remember that Donald Trump was in
Israel last week he was apparently so
triggered by the possibility of being
heckled during a speech that he abruptly
canceled it Trump was scheduled to
address the Israeli Parliament called
the Knesset but Israel Israel Speaker of
the House Yuli Edelstein told an Israeli
radio station that the Trump
administration canceled the speech
because self-pitying Trump was just
afraid of the response that he would get
during the trip even though Trump has
tried so hard to seem pro-israel during
his trip and during his campaign and
while being president he's actually very
unpopular among many members of the
Knesset which is kind of pathetic in and
of itself Speaker of the Knesset Yuli
Edelstein said to Israeli army radio
quote the possibility was explored as a
first option and it was dropped from the
agenda because it was clear that the
president wouldn't be able to speak
instead Donald Trump went to safeSpace
Israel Museum in Jerusalem which was I
guess a much more comfortable
environment for him where people weren't
going to be mean and things would be
much easier and calmer for him past
presidents have spoken to Israel's
parliament during their visits it's sort
of a tradition but also past presidents
were able to read well and didn't mock
disabled reporters on camera so we're
seeing a lot of firsts under the trump
presidency wasn't Trump the tough guy
Pat Trump Zillah
he can handle anything he can tell
people what's what and yet he doesn't
want to be heckled so he bails I think
this is the ultimate irony of these all
trite types which is that they are the
special snowflakes and yes they
obviously view Trump as their alpha not
exactly working out that way and this is
similar to the whole White House
Correspondents Dinner thing which
presidents almost always attend and
Trump said it was something about what
was the explanation he gave her why he
wasn't going there's more important
things to be doing or something he had
that rally planned he had that big rally
in front of
the supporters yet campaign rally or
something like that I actually thought
when I read this well Trump's going to
make up for this by doing a campaign
rally where his own security can just
throw out protesters in case in point
next week Trump is doing one of these
rallies even though the campaign is over
in Cedar Rapids Iowa walking punch line
here